these days
you're likely to find brittany howard
knee-deep in the elk river in southern
tennessee
[Music]
[Applause]
it's where we would have caught up with
her if not for covid
i was really hoping to go fishing i was
really looking forward to taking you
fishing
if for example if i wasn't talking to
you i would have been fishing but i
happily am talking to you right now
the alabama-born singer has become known
for her otherworldly presence on stage
tyler the creator said of you britney is
an
alien everything about her it's so
unique
well i love tyler for saying that do you
feel like an alien in some way
all the time i wouldn't be surprised if
a spaceship landed right now and just
like are we going to take you back home
and i'd be like i knew it
[Laughter]
[Music]
howard was raised in athens alabama
where the video for her song
stay high was filmed
[Music]
my dad he's kind of like the unofficial
mayor
everybody knows him everybody recognizes
his last
big lash her dad ran a junkyard with her
mom
when britney was growing up when you
started with the alabama shakes you were
actually
still working delivering mail right
that's right yeah
working like a 13-hour day delivering
mail and whatnot
and then speeding over to rehearsal
because i didn't want to miss rehearsal
because it was
my favorite thing in life
alabama shakes debut album in 2012
immediately put them on the map
[Music]
and would sell more than a million
copies
their follow-up went to number one and
earned three grammys
but howard heard another voice within
her and in 2017
went out on her own whether people
believe it or not it takes courage to do
it
because you have to be prepared to fail
you know you also got to be prepared to
succeed
[Music]
last year she released her debut solo
album
jamie named after her older sister who
died of a rare cancer
when britney was eight that must have
been devastating
yeah it was devastating i think it
changed my entire family
her parents soon split howard
started playing guitar did your sister
introduce you to music in a way oh yeah
definitely you know she had like the
cassette box the full
cassette tapes and she basically was
giving me permission to like every type
of music
from a super young age
[Music]
howard's new music is her most
vulnerable
georgia is a love song from one girl
to another
i kind of wrote it from a perspective of
like an innocent love
and realizing when you're young that
you're different as a little girl being
attracted to
older girls or just other girls to me it
just felt like
a story that needed to be told another
song
goat head is a true story
[Music]
about the harassment her parents faced
as an interracial couple but what i
really want to know
[Music]
a story they only shared with her years
later
because my parents were trying to do a
really good job of making me
not fear where i live or the people
that's around me
and i didn't grow up that way i didn't
grow up in fear during the pandemic
howard has had time to reflect do you
feel like your voice
is more important in this moment
[Music]
i don't know it seems like everybody is
important
i've been blessed to have a life of
duality i've seen both sides i've been
impoverished and i've been wealthy and
you know i have a
white side of my family a black side of
my family you know i'm gay i've tried to
be straight you know try to do all those
things and
um it's it's blessed me with such an
expansive
knowledge of empathy
it's hard to find things to look forward
to right now what are you looking
forward to
i look forward to uh catching my next
fish
i'm curious when you're fishing do you
ever write songs uh yeah i sing to the
fish
yeah jump on this hook jump on this hook
jump on his hook hey hey hey
i hope i get my fishing trip one day and
i hope she gets some grammy nominations
because that's a great album
i'll tell you i would now want to get it
if you're if you're wondering about the
alabama shakes she says the door is
always open she just wants to make music
for herself right now
yeah but she's fascinating she's amazing
i liked her i love everything about it
she's terrific in the album it's
terrific we'll be